hi I'm Greg I'm John it continues it
continued to slash 16 seconds but really
it's probably like 10 with all the
titles they throw in there and probably
the ending bit of showing the Justice
League let's do this my friend let's
make it happen
oh snap diggity okay I really like the
blue effect they have with the flash cuz
I don't have ever in the comics but I've
seen the first two seasons of the show
yeah and this that on the premiere of
the musical the flash super go crossover
saying oh man no you know the flashes
red like red lightning or whatever red
thread you don't I get it and here the
Lighting's blue really differentiy to
different version or how they opt use a
lot different totally yeah
who is a darker color and movies want to
be done I feel like the biggest pressure
out of all the characters in here is
really riding on Ezra Miller though
because the flash is such a beloved show
and it the answer that a great hint
there were people who were upset at the
fact that they weren't gonna you know
put ezrin they were going to put Grant
Gustin in there and the role so I feel
like as her Miller has the most
responsibility to show like new you can
do a different taking it will work
within this will be really cool there
yeah yeah and we can have them coexisted
yeah that's the thing he has to co-exist
and anything as such it was gonna be
like you should adjust what Ezra Miller
in there I mean uh you know Gregerson
that's a bit yeah I enjoyed this room
Miller's a few few things I've seen him
in and like I don't know these little
images are I almost feel like Adam
because you showed me the other two
before we watch this I feel like this is
the most exciting one so far just
because like you only got like three
images of in but you're like there's a
good dream solitary images man like that
little like preparation are you and it
seems like it's centering himself
although his outfit seems like a much
updated version of the kind of outfits
we saw on the Mighty Morphin Power this
is a new salad everything the head
plates and featuring everything's really
designed it's always cool I mean looks a
little spiritual or something here he's
doing it
yeah he's prepping himself to go
speedster on us I feel like he's also
the character I'm most excited to see
this because from the little things I've
seen of him I like him the most so yeah
these guys
I feel like you find most relatable for
you especially yeah dirty TV dude thanks
man
yeah yeah you having problems but that
shower is running it through it's really
cool like the images that I've seen of
it showing up the cooling is Batman
Aquaman up flash like I want to watch
the IMAX this kind of gets me excited
for the kinds of things I know Zack
Snyder is good at totally so uh so yeah
I guess good job all right well you got
two more Justice Li people would go
libel a hopefully I'll be around my my
apartment did shoot those on time yeah
we got a few things we got to take care
of and on Saturday when it actually
dropped depending on the time of drops I
have to go to an event on Saturday for
house yeah I'm going to a bra funny ring
honey ranch in Vegas evil booked my
protégée bush not brought into reserves
never been with a [ __ ] before Oh a
little oh yeah a little low person there
mm-hmm
little Irish [ __ ] a little new to the
channel you can subscribe you the real
region a good friend where I tell only
truth on this channel truth that only
the most polite true John reason giant
Twitter Instagram social media manager
of Blum house and the real rejects and
shout out to the DCE you
I have faith you can recover I really do
yeah I really good gonna be this one I
want stay where my hope lies but I'm
thinking my for more films from now okay
well they're really gonna enjoy
strapping Wonder Woman gonna be good I
really do everything one room will be
good
Justice League same guy did like you
know every graphic answer that yeah I I
think this is glad it sociable